das tempo ist rasant
das ziel entgegen
auf diesem schiff gibt es immer was zu
tun
sie ist nicht leicht zu manövrieren
die landschaft ist atemberaubend ein
wahl doch das meer ist tückisch
wir müssen auf alle ländlichen notfälle
vorbereitet sein
in europa ist allein auf weiter flur
sind der könig des nordatlantiks
in rhöner ist frachtschiff und
fährschiff in einem sie ist auf einem
besonders schwierigen schiffsroute
unterwegs 365 tage im jahr
eine wichtige strecke von den
ferieninseln nach dänemark und island
kapitän patrick voller nun hat schon als
junger mann auf see gearbeitet erst auf
fischerbooten dann auf containerschiff
15 jetzt ist er zurück auf den färöer
inseln als kapitän der norina
jeder auf den früheren kennt ihn
erinnern
die färöer sind eine gruppe von 18
inseln sie liegen im nordatlantik
zwischen dänemark und island
ja was sagt die karte
jede woche macht das schiff eine
siebentägige rundreise
von hirtshals in dänemark nach torshavn
hauptstadt der färöer dann weiter nach
island und über die färöer inseln zurück
nach dänemark
es ist mitte mai
kurz vor 9 uhr
läuft in den hafen von hirtshals im
norden dänemarks 1 die fahrerin und
halte neben der gateway
im gegensatz zum schiff
wenn das schiff in den hafen ein pferd
macht es einer 180 grad drehung damit
die laderampe am kai andocken kann
der kapitän lässt die riesige 70 tonnen
rampe schon kurz vorm andocken runter
14 90
900 ist die rampe unten
[Musik]
es ist kein einfaches man hört
doch genau das liebt der kapitän in
seinem job wir sind auf position wir an
bat lassen
erster offizier boogie pettersson hat
alle hände voll zu tun autos von lkw und
er muss das ganze schiff entladen und
wieder bilder
alles in sechs stunden
jetzt im frühling ist es ethisch und es
kommen viele touristen
heute bus pettersson nicht nur mit 180
lastzügen fertig werden sondern auch mit
171 pkw und 13 wohnwagen ich muss immer
alles im blick haben
er ist gerade von der fähre gefahren
die busse müssen wir umstellen
mit hilfe dieser skizze plant peter
szondi beladung
was in island entladen werden soll muss
zuerst aufs schiff
gelb geht nach island grün auf die fähre
es ist wie ein puzzle mit fehlenden
teilen
heute macht ein puzzleteil probleme
einlass zu 120 meter lang
das ist zu lang
hier haben wir nur 18 meter 50
das passt nicht ein kleiner rechenfehler
mit großen folgen später schon muss
schnell überlegen wie er die lkw neu
anordnet
ihr passt das kann ja kommt auf deck
vier
im hotelbereich des schiffs bereitet die
housekeeping crew den passagierbereich
fuhren
auf deck 8 wird sie in die kabinen
stewardessen die letzten betten
in ein paar stunden kommen 800 gäste an
bord für eine einfache kabine zahlen sie
zwischen 200 und 1000 euro
[Musik]
marion siegmund dort hier arbeitet schon
lange als kabinen stewardess
mir geht es
in zwei stunden müssen alle kabinen
bezugsfertig sein
ich bin neu wusste treffen
barbaro schwick hat noch probleme mit
der orientierung
ich habe mich nie hat vor zehn tagen
angeheuert
alles sieht gleich aus ich
ende immer wieder im gleichen
aber das wird schon
[Musik]
seit acht ist fertig
13 uhr die ersten passagiere jenen bord
80 lastzüge heute
daher ist einer unter deck hat fracht
manager mike lenzen es sagen hier wird
jeder zentimeter genutzt
ich muss ein auge auf meinem team haben
das ist ein gefährlicher ort
es ist unübersichtlich
die decke helfer weisen die lkw fahrer
ein
sie müssen ein gutes augenmaß haben der
abstand zwischen den lastzügen darf
höchstens 5 cm betragen
wenn der abstand zu groß ist passt der
letzte lastzug nicht mehr rein
das wäre schlecht
die uhr tickt
die hafen sicherheit kontrolliert jeden
lastzug bevor er an bord kommt
ich sehe mir jetzt mal das fach zwischen
den reifen
heute ist es allerdings leer
dieser
sicherheitsmitarbeiter sucht blinde
passagiere meistens flüchtlinge die über
island in die usa reisen wollen
sie verstecken sich unten bei den rädern
wenn wir welche finden übergeben wir sie
der polizei
die sicherheitsmitarbeiter haben eine
erfolgsquote von 95 prozent
heute finden sie keinen blinden
passagieren
14 uhr in einer stunde soll die neue
rhöner ablegt
wer mit dem auto kommt
muss es selber im frachtraum parken
manche fahrer tun sich beim einparken
schwerer als andere
[Musik]
die drei großen fracht text den rhöner
sind über rampen verbunden
stehen eine fahrzeuge auf dem obersten
parkdeck wird die rampe hoch gelassen
jetzt können darunter weitere autos
parken
dieses system spart platz so passen bis
zu 800 autos auf 26
[Musik]
die rampe zwischendeck 3 und 4 kann
ebenfalls hoch gelassen werden darunter
ist platz für kühltransporter und busse
nach fünf stunden ist fast alles
verladen nur ein besonders sperriges
frachtgut muss noch an bord
alles auf stopp
die crew hat gummireifen ausgelegt damit
die ketten des 87 tonnen baggers die
laderampe nicht beschädigen
[Musik]
der bagger ist an gott aber es gibt ein
problem er steht zu nah an der
sprinkleranlage
scheffel
das ist zu knapp das geht nicht
sie müssen den bagger umparken doch es
gibt nicht genug platz
wenn wir es nicht schaffen was er aus
jensen unseren team müssen eine lösung
finden sie können den bagger auf keinen
fall in hirtshals lassen
die ms löhner hätte bereits vor 40
minuten ablegen sollen so könnte das
klappen
fracht manager jensen und sein team sind
immer noch dabei diesen riesenbagger im
frachtraum unterzubringen es sind zwei
zentimeter oder nur einer
der bagger steht zu nah an der
sprinkleranlage
wir versuchen
es muss klappen
es ist millimeterarbeit
ok
der packer darf nicht an die
sprinkleranlage kommen
endlich der bagger ist sicher verstaut
das passt gut
die rampe am heck wird hochgefahren
und die taue von den pollern los gemacht
leinen los den rhöner verlässt den hafen
mit einer stunde verspätung
der kapitän ist zuversichtlich er wird
die zeit wieder aufholen mit 15 5 knoten
holen wir das locker wieder rein es
reicht sogar wenn nur zwei motoren
laufen
wir kommen
[Musik]
die neumühler steuert ihren ersten
zwischenstopp an vorschauen auf den
verhören
[Musik]
die fahrt dauert ungefähr anderthalb
tage
für eine strecke von knapp über 1000
kilometern
[Musik]
um halb fünf am nächsten morgen dämmert
es bereits in den frühlingsmonaten ist
es im nordatlantik im durchschnitt 15
stunden lang hell
der atlantik ist launisch
kein tag ist wie der andere
die vip geschwindigkeit beträgt 38
knoten das sind 70 kilometer die stunde
die wellen sind bis zu vier meter hoch
bei diesem wetter ist es eine echte
herausforderung die fracht ohne große
verspätung zu liefern
im frachtraum sind zwei entdeckt helfer
dabei die verzerrungen zu überprüfen
sollte sich ein 20 tonnen lösen hätte
das katastrophale folgen
auf dem autodeck kontrollieren sie ob
alle pkw noch an ort und stelle stehen
wenn die handbremse nicht angezogen sind
könnten autos beschädigt werden
bei starkem seegang gehen ab und zu
alarmanlagen an
[Musik]
grüner wurde so gebaut dass sie starken
wellengang die stirn bieten kann
sie ist breiter als andere
darum bleibt sie auch noch stabil wenn
wählen sie mittig oder
raue see macht ihr nichts aus
zwei schiffs stabilisatoren sorgen dafür
dass die passagiere nicht seekrank
werden
bei starkem seegang werden 57 meter
langer bewegliche flossen ausgefahren
sie arbeiten gegen die rolle bewegung
des schiffes darum gibt es nicht zu
stark
sie sind verbot dem schiff macht seegang
nichts aus
den passagieren schon
dank der stabilisatoren bekommen sie vom
starken wellengang kaum etwas mit
die passagiere sollen sich wolf
trotzdem haben einige passagiere am
frühstücksbuffet noch ihre probleme mit
dem schaukeln
sie sind in wellengang nicht gewohnt
erster offizier boogie petterson kennt
das problem nur zu gut
viele passagiere rechnen einfach nicht
mit einer rauen see
die meisten passagiere wissen allerdings
welches wetter sie bei dieser fahrt
erwartet
der wind weht alle meine sorgen davon
wir lieben regen und wind
der wind zaust mannheim
trennen sind freudentränen
solch stürmischen bedingungen sind ideal
für die küstenwache
sie proben eine höhenrettung
dabei soll sich eine rettungskraft aufs
deck ab
die küstenwache will diesen einsatz bei
starkem wind durchspielen
der hubschrauber ist auf den
shetlandinseln gestartet es ist eine
übung sie wissen dass wir hier oft
entlang fahren jetzt machen sie sich
bereit
alle kameras sind auf den sogenannten
winden führer im hubschrauber gerichtet
doch der wind ist zu stark
der helikopter der küstenwache zieht
unverrichteter dinge wieder ab
ein paar ganz besonderen gästen im
frachtraum ist das schlechte wetter
herzlich egal
schuler schädling und nachher doch zum
glück nie seekrank
sie kommen von einem reitturnier in
dänemark und fahren jetzt nach hause auf
die färöer inseln landor daly ist froh
dass es den rhöner gibt
wir können mit den pferden zu turnieren
in dänemark norwegen und holland fahren
ohne den euro wäre das nicht möglich sie
ist unser weg aufs europäische festland
[Musik]
checkliste erledigt
ihr tränen über backbord
entstehen
16 uhr 45 am dritten tag der reise die
norweger fährt in den hafen von thor
schauen der hauptstadt der färöer inseln
ein strahl ruder
in torshavn anzulegen ist alles andere
als ein einfaches manöver
[Musik]
der kapitän muss sich der anlegestelle
mit der steuerbordseite annähern dann
dreht er das schiff um 180 grad jetzt
liegt es parallel zum 4 nur noch 15
meter davon entfernt
nun heißt es seitwärts einfahren ein
stück rückwärts dann ist das
anlegemanöver beendet
wir dürfen keinen fehler macht
der hafen ist winzig im vergleich zu
unserem schiff
dieses manöver führt der kapitän
komplett manuell aus er vertraut dabei
auf seine erfahrung
kurz vor 5 uhr am nächsten morgen
die neumühler läuft in die ferien
hauptstadt torshavn 1
[Musik]
der kapitän muss das schiff um 180 grad
drehen es wird mit der backbordseite am
pier festgemacht
auch die brille damit ich alles sehe
die kleinste abweichung vom kurs wäre
fatal
den rhöner ist nur 20 meter vom 54 meter
von einigen feldern entfernt
es ist wichtig dass man der chef
darf sich bei diesem manöver auf keinen
fall überschätzen
der kapitän richtet die steuer ruder
unter wasser auf backbord
die propeller auf backbordseite stellt
er auf volle fahrt rückwärts
der steuerbord propeller bleibt wie er
ist auf halber fahrt voraus
vorne am schiff drücken zwei strahlen
ruder den bug richtung anlegestelle
jetzt liegt das schiff parallel zur
anlegestelle
der kapitän muss die ruder und propeller
vorsichtig einsetzen langsam legt er
ansetzt zurück und lässt die rampe
runter
er ist von seinen fähigkeiten so
überzeugt dass er die rampe schon runter
lässt bevor das schiff in position ist
von
sechs würfen
der kapitän das schiff in nur acht
minuten angelegt wie ein schweizer
uhrwerk ganz auf seine art ohne die
unterstützung von hafenlotsen oder
schleppern
zu viele leute auf der brücke würden
nicht nur stören ich brauch das nicht
zuschauen ist nur ein zwischenstopp in
neun stunden sticht die neue rhöner
schon wieder in see sie muss also
schnell entladen werden
[Musik]
den 87 tonnen schweren bagger aus dem
frachtraum rauszubekommen geht deutlich
schneller als in rein zu bekommen
[Musik]
grüner macht hier zweimal pro woche
zwischenstopp sie liefert wichtige
gegenstände
wir brauchen dämmstoff sperrholz und
bauholz fast alles bringt ihnen rhöner
mit
tatsächlich muss jede art von holz per
schiff geliefert werden auf den verhören
gibt es nämlich keine bäume
den rhöner bringt auch touristen auf die
insel
die passagiere in den reisebussen rächen
zu einer fünfstündigen rundfahrt auf
hier gibt es unberührte natur
im neunten jahrhundert besiedelten
wikinger die färöer-inseln
gesprochen wird hier fällig
die hälfte der 50.000 einwohner lebt in
kleinen dörfern die schafe auf der insel
sind ihnen zahlenmäßig weit überlegen
abfahrt
keine zeit zu verlieren
um 15 uhr sind alle passagiere wieder an
bord die neuköllner sticht in see
[Musik]
ich las dreimal das horner töne
die passagiere mögen es auch
[Musik]
von thor schauen aus durchquerte lorena
die inselgruppe und nimmt kurs richtung
nordwest
etwa 18 stunden dauert ihre reise bis
nach st dies würde auf island
genug zeit für die passagiere die
eindrucksvollen natur zu gefunden
es ist toll zwischen den inseln
durchzufahren
jedes mal
das schiff ist wieder auf offener see
und die passagiere tina um frank jensen
machen es sich auf dem deck gemütlich
hier entspannen wir sie reisen zum
dritten mal mit der nön
unsere freunde verstehen nicht dass wir
mit dem schiff nach island fahren sie
denken man wird sehen ob es ist einfach
toll
generöser fährt 23 knoten
nur drei der vier motoren laufen
sie nutzt die strömung
ich lasse jetzt den vorderen
ballasttanks der
kapitän nimmt ballastwasser auf um
treibstoff zu sparen und befülle diesen
tag
im vorderen ballasttanks sind jetzt 500
tonnen wasser dadurch liegt der gewichts
schwerpunkt tief genug
es fahren mit ballast verringert den
auftrieb des schiffes dadurch gewinnt es
an stabilität und fährt sicherer
mit dieser methode
sparen wir zwölf prozent
stabilisatoren einfahren halb neun am
vierten tag der reise in rhynern er sich
der küste islams trackliste für ankunft
morgen hier spricht der kapitän wir
nähern uns zwei bis vier
[Musik]
kleine fischerboote sind ein problem
wir sehen sie auf den radar
augen und ohren offen heim
der hafen ist klein aber der kapitän hat
hier schon tausend mal angedockt
er weiß genau an welchen punkten er sich
orientieren muss wenn er ein pferd
beim dritten fenster sind in position
ein hafenarbeiter unten am pier ist da
jedoch anderer meinung
um 8.14
[Musik]
sind sich alle einig die nur öner hat
angelegt
in den nächsten 35 stunden in island
gibt es viel zu tun
die neue renault liegt im isländischen
havelse es für
sie bleibt dort zwei tage die vier
hauptmotoren stehen still nur ein
hilfsmotor läuft noch
die schiffstechnik können jetzt wichtige
wartungsarbeiten durchführen
der leitende ingenieur news weiß was zu
tun ist hier sehen wir die
maschinenräume
zuerst muss ein turbolader ersetzt
werden
dafür brauchen die techniker etwa 20
stunden
turbolader steigern die motorleistung
indem sie den luftdurchsatz erhöhen sie
müssen regelmäßig gereinigt werden
wir können das nur hier in island machen
weil der motor dafür abkühlen muss
mussten
die techniker bauen den 22 tonnen
schweren turbolader aus und zerlegen sie
suchen nach schwefel ablagerungen
gehäuse und filter während er reinigt
die rumpftruppe turbolader ist sehr
schwer sie wiegt etwa 600
die techniker brauchen eine winde um sie
auszubauen
niemand möchte dass das teil unter 5
er war die ganz unten landen
der schaden wäre enorm
draußen am 4
das reicht wird für den ernstfall
geprobt kapitän und erster offizier
so ziehen
leiten das sicherheitstraining für die
neuen auf dem schiff wasser marsch
das wird er kann schnell umschlagen
der satzung muss für alle notfälle
gewappnet
wir zielen nicht so weit nach oben
sondern in diese richtung immer von
schiff weg nicht richtung dorf
erst
bei einem unfall auf see
müssen alle wissen was zu tun ist
auch kabinen stewardess barbara rossig
sie hat genau zwei minuten um den
überlebensanzug anzuziehen mein erstes
mal aufregen
das wasser ist eisige 5 grad kalt
[Musik]
sagen sie
in diesem anzug überlebt man sechs
stunden im kalten wasser
alle müssen zum rettungslos schwimmen
und rein klettern
leichter gesagt als getan
man kann sich in dem anzug kaum bewegen
irgendwohin schwimmen ist schwer
anstrengend
nach diesen kurs wissen alle worauf sie
notfall ankommt
kalt oder
die passagiere nutzen unterdessen die
zeit um island zu erkunden
wer seinen geländewagen dabei hat kann
die spektakuläre landschaft offroad
erkunden
dieser ort ist ein besonderes highlight
das 1250 hektar große naturschutzgebiet
collins
tag 2 in island diese fahrzeuge warten
darauf an bord zu fahren
doch eine der klappen der 72 tonnen
rampe ist locker sie schließt nicht
ordnungsgemäß
die rampe muss repariert werden
ich überprüfe alle bolzen der rampe
solange der fehler nicht gefunden ist
fährt die nur öner nirgendwo hin
wir reparieren das in island hier haben
wir die zeit und das nötige werkzeug
die 400 kilo schweren klappen werden
über einen hydraulik motor angetrieben
einer der schläuche für die
hydraulikflüssigkeit muss ausgetauscht
werden
bord ingenieur sie grotjahn 1000
entdeckt außerdem ein aus geschlagenes
lager um dort einen neuen bolzen
einsetzen zu können muss er die lager
stillen aus spindel
dauert einen tag
[Musik]
währenddessen im maschinen kommen
arbeiter setzen den turbolader wieder
ein
er wurde grundüberholt und ist wieder
einsatzbereit
bott ingenieur 1000 arbeitet unter
hochdruck
er ist gerade dabei den bolzen an der
fehlerhaften rampe auszuwechseln unter
dem kritischen blick seines chefs wir
müssen schnell fertig werden die ersten
pkw und wohnmobile warten schon sie
wollen an bord fahren
wenn das schiff zu spät startet müsste
es mit maximalleistung fahren um die
zeit aufzuholen das würde
treibstoffkosten
zeit ist geld wenn alle vier motoren
laufen verbrennen wir vier tonnen öl pro
stunde
jede stunde verspätung kostet die
schifffahrtsgesellschaft also eine
stange geld
in vier stunden soll die neue rhöner
ablehnen doch wenn die rampe nicht
repariert ist bleibt sie im hafen
die heck rampe den rhöner lässt sich
immer noch nicht vollständig schließen
bord ingenieur 1000 hat mittlerweile
einen der hydraulikschläuche der hack
rampe ausgetauscht
war sie ein kleines stück
die stunde der wahrheit
sie haben nur eine rampe wenn sie nicht
funktioniert können wir die autos nicht
aufs schiff lassen
um halb fünf gibt tausend grünes licht
die fehlerhafte klappe schließt zwar
langsamer als die anderen aber immerhin
sie schließt vollständig
wir können das schiff jetzt belegen die
klappe funktioniert wieder
gerade noch rechtzeitig
in drei stunden müssen alle fahrzeuge an
bord sein
20 uhr 30 im haupt maschinen um die crew
hat sich bereit die norweger aus dem
hafen zu manövrieren
guten abend motoren starten wir starten
die motoren
hilfsmotor ausschalten
die vier hauptmotoren mit insgesamt
30.000 ps setzen die antriebswelle im nu
in bewegung kapitän und leitender
ingenieur arbeiten schon seit jahren
zusammen sie sind ein eingespieltes team
ich habe hier unten das sagen er oben
auf der brücke
es ist wichtig dass wir uns aufeinander
verlassen können
er ist für das schiff verantwortlich und
vertraut darauf dass im maschinenraum
alles wie geschmiert
die neumühler verlässt den sicheren
hafen
[Musik]
auf dem offenen meer erwarten sie
windgeschwindigkeiten von 35 knoten
ein sturm zieht auf der kapitän überlegt
wie er das unwetter umfallen kann
der sturm ist südlich von uns
der rote bereich auf der karte ist kein
sturm sondern ein orkan das bedeutet
über zehn meter hohe wellen die nur
einer fährt zwar nicht direkt durch das
schlechtwetter gebiet trotzdem ist der
segler auf ihrer route stark der kapitän
ändert den kurs damit die gäste vom
größten verschont werden
und erwarten drei bis vier meter hohe
wellen womit das wiz
mittlerweile ist es nacht die meisten
gäste werden also kaum etwas mitbekommen
beim frühstück am nächsten morgen haben
sie ordentlichen appetit
die nur einer fährt zurück nach dänemark
und macht wieder einen kurzen
zwischenstopp in tor schaut
am fährterminal warten lkw mit einer
ganz besonderen ladung
[Musik]
in 85 prozent der lastzüge ist frischer
fisch aus dem nordatlantik
50 bis 60 lkw bringen lachs in alle
ecken von europa
diese fische sind für die wirtschaft der
färöer-inseln goldwert fischerei
produkte allen voran die last zucht
machen etwa 95 prozent des deutschen
exports aus unseren
vier unternehmen erzeugen und
exportieren zuchtlachs auf den färöer
inseln
jedes unternehmen verschifft pro woche
etwa acht bis zehn lkw-ladungen lachs im
wert von 1,1 bis 1,4 millionen euro
ohne die nur hühner hätten dir keinen
zugang zu wichtigen märkten die russland
und osteuropa
sie ist also sehr wichtig für uns
fisch muss frisch sein er muss also so
schnell wie möglich nach dänemark kommen
heute ist donnerstag
montagmorgen sollte dieser lachs im
regal
es ist 21 uhr 30 in rhöner hätte vor
einer halben stunde auslaufen sollen die
motoren laufen schon alles wartet auf
einen lkw der aufgehalten wurde
deckel verschließen die lkw anhänger an
ein bord eigenes kühlsystem an
der fisch muss bei minus 24 grad
gelagert werden
das ist dringend nötig der fisch in
diesem lkw anhänger ist etwa
144000 euro wert
um 22 uhr legt in rhöner ab
morgen beendet sie ihre rundreise in
dänemark
in der kombüse haben chefkoch rea gb
und sein team voller arbeit geleistet
freitag ist besonders hektisch sie haben
den nur acht stunden ein galadiner für
400 gäste gezogen
das galadiner ist eine willkommene
abwechslung zum allabendlichen buffet
zu ehren der früheren siedler der fahrer
gibt es ein wikinger festmahl mit
passender dekoration
nichts für vegetarier
das essen ist sehr deftig
es gibt fleisch
auch für eingefleischte fans gibt es am
buffet überraschung
das ist
eine typische spezialität
schafskopf
[Musik]
ein wahres fest für fleischliebhaber die
hungrige meute wartet schon
bringt alles raus der letzte abend an
bord der norina in der kombüse geht es
rund
in zehn minuten werden die passagiere
über das wikinger buffet herfallen
für die über 400 hungrigen gäste stehen
einige leckerbissen bereit
ganz
rinderzunge bild
schweinchen und ente
und
auf einem felsen schiff darf natürlich
auf frische fisch nicht fehlen
[Musik]
viele passagiere wollen unseren fisch
probieren
man schmeckt den unterschied
bei uns gibt es den besten live stage
den lachs ihr hin auch die bedingungen
passen optisch zum thema wikinger
spektakel
zum schluss noch etwas fleisch
showtime
[Musik]
ein passagierzug sogar sein
taschenmesser um ein stück vom
schafskopf abzuschneiden
[Musik]
der nächste morgen 8 uhr gleich fährt
die nur rhöner in den dänischen hafen
herz als ein hier begann vor einer woche
ihre 3000 kilometer lange reise
stabilisatoren einfahren die besatzung
hat in diesen sieben tagen die norina
viermal be und entladen
nichts neues für den ersten offizier
peter soll erfährt diese strecke seit
neun jahren
für mich ist das arbeitsalltag
er hält große stücke auf den ordner und
ihre besatzung
es ist ein tolles schiff sie fährt sich
wie ein teures auto gibt ihr ein sehr
teurer bentley
als kapitän an voll an um in den hafen
ein fährt nutzt er die gelegenheit zu
zeigen was er kann
das war's
[Musik]
bei leichtem wind aus osten dreht er den
rhöner um 180 grad eher manövriert das
165 meter lange schiff rückwärts und
dockt es ohne mühe ampere an
ein kinderspiel der kapitän ist
zufrieden er ist stolz darauf ein schiff
wie die norina steuern zu dürfen
wir sind kleine wikinger
es ist eine ehre werk als kapitän dieses
schiffes den spuren der wikinger zufall
im nordatlantik und
nach der reise ist vor der reise
in rhöner verbindet 365 tage im jahr die
faröer inseln mit dem rest europas